paulina buenos días gracias y cómo
calificar estos 15 años del liderazgo de
la que sabemos es una de las mujeres más
influyentes del planeta
bueno buenos días ha sido un liderazgo
de altos y bajos como tus señaladas en
la introducción porque ella ha tenido
que gestionar muchas crisis tanto crisis
a nivel europeo nivel internacional como
también al interior de la propia
alemania y su propio partido y dentro de
esta evolución de los 15 años y como
ella ha gestionado estas distintas
crisis o tensiones ha ido marcando un
sello muy especial muy relacionado con
su propia forma de ser con su
experiencia de vida como tú señalada
nacida
en la alemania cosas cría de la alemania
oriental y con rasgos particulares que
le dan confianza y estabilidad no sólo a
los alemanes sino que a europa en
general siento alemania tan importante
en la integración europea
y mire la crisis de los migrantes por
ejemplo fue un punto de inflexión en los
años recientes de su gobierno ahora la
crisis del coronavirus también ha
marcado sus políticas recientes sea una
de las voces más fuertes además por la
unidad europea que sigue para el país y
cómo afecta esto a la comunidad europea
o sea es la gran pregunta y preocupación
que tiene muchos en europa porque angela
merkel representaba aquella moderación y
aquí ya vos que a veces se demoraba
mucho en llegar como el caso de la
crisis griega que fue muy criticada pero
que actúa muy rápido ahora en la crisis
la pandemia lo que le ha dado también a
europa una tranquilidad de poder tener
recursos e incluso rompiendo mitos que
alemania no quería cruzar cierta línea
roja y ella lo hizo lo que se le critica
a ella es que no ha dejado claramente un
sucesor o sucesora dentro de dentro del
partido no se sabe quién va a
reemplazarla ella había dejado al
principio a una una sucesora y fue
presidenta del partido pero no resultó
renunció luego de algunas derrotas a
nivel nacional por lo tanto no se sabe y
ella dice que no va a continuar después
del 2021 pese a que ya varios sectores
sólo están pidiendo justamente porque se
requiere estabilidad y certidumbre y
ella justamente lo que le da a europa y
lo que más necesita en estos tiempos
vientos que se están viviendo no sólo
por la comida sino también por los
cambios en el escenario internacional